nous avons l'honneur de recevoir
aujourd'hui Monsieur Jacques Attali qui
que l'on ne présente plus parmi ces
nombreuses activités notamment présidé
la Commission pour la libéralisation de
la croissance entre juin 2016 et
libération et non pas libéralisation
et pas ça
toutes les excuses la libération de la
croissance entre juin 2007 et janvier
2008 monsieur adaïs je vous souhaite la
bienvenue je vous remercie pour votre
présence afin de nous éclairer sur des
travaux anciens mais qui reste
manifestement toujours d'actualité en
juin 2007 le Président de la République
française Nicolas Sarkozy vous demande
de constituer une équipe et de rédiger
un rapport fournissant des
recommandations et de propositions afin
de relancer la croissance économique de
la France après 6 mois de travaux la
commission que vous présidez a rendu son
rapport final le 23 janvier 2008 lequel
préconisé notamment de supprimer les
rentes réduire les privilèges et
favorisé les mobilités plus précisément
dans le secteur de la mobilité même si
parler de beaucoup de différents
secteurs d'activités dans ce rapport
naturellement la proposition 209 de
votre rapport préconisé une ouverture
complète du marché et taxi et des
véhicules de petites remises parisiens
de nature à générer un gain d'emploi de
35000 à 45000
personnes si vous auditionnons 15 ans
après la remise du premier rapport de
cette commission Monsieur Attali c'est
qu'il est ressorti des premières
auditions de notre commission d'enquête
que cette recommandation c'est à
commencer à ouvrir un débat un débat
d'ailleurs qui était ancien en
l'occurrence sur la question de des
licences de taxi l'ouverture à la
concurrence ou la dérégulation du
secteur des taxis avant même l'arrivée
des acteurs que l'on connaît et auxquels
notre commission s'intéresse de près
uber et les différentes plateformes de
VTC notre commission d'enquête à deux
objectifs d'une part pour objet
d'identifier l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying qui a été men par uber pourra
s'implanter en France le rôle des
décideurs publics de l'époque et mettent
des recommandations concernant
l'encadrement des relations entre les
décideurs publics et les représentants
d'intérêt et d'autre part pour ambition
d'évaluer les conséquences économiques
sociales environnementales du
développement du modèle uber en France
et les réponses apportées et à apporter
par les décideurs publics évidemment ce
qui nous intéresse dans le fait d'avoir
votre perspective sur les débats de
l'époque et peut-être d'ailleurs les
débats même qui ont précédé la remise de
votre rapport et la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est qu'on voit que
cette question de la pénurie ou non de
l'offre de transport particulier de
personnes en France en particulier à
Paris de la régulation et donc de la
possibilité de créer des emplois
préexister bien sûr à l'arrivée des
plateformes et au lobbying de ces
plateformes donc c'est pour toutes ces
questions que nous aurions nous voulons
vous vous interroger et bien sûr avoir
votre perspective sur les débats qui ont
suivi et les débats liés à
l'implantation du beurre et des autres
acteurs des des VTC
je vous rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale je vous précise
également que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires imposent de
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous inviter
à lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure voilà merci
Monsieur Je vous laissais la parole mais
vous le voyez nous sommes très
intéressés par la perspective que vous
avez sur les débats au moment de votre
commission mais aussi avant et après sur
la question du secteur des de transport
particulier de personnes alors je vous
remercie monsieur Président c'est une
occasion de revenir 15 ans en arrière
d'abord cette commission et le petit
échange précédent elle a bien montré
était pour moi
quelque chose qui ne pouvait être
accepté par moi homme de gauche qu'à
condition que le président de l'époque
Nicolas Sarkozy et son premier ministre
ont parfaitement accepté à savoir que ça
soit une commission bip artisan
dont j'étais libre de premièrement de
choisir les membres et ils n'ont fait
aucun effort pour m'imposer qui que ce
soit et ça a été une commission
bipartisane il y avait à la fois
des leaders syndicaux des leaders
patronaux des intellectuels des
étrangers enfin c'est une commission
aussi équilibrée possible
deuxièmement décrire moi-même la lettre
qu'il m'enverrait et ils l'ont respecté
parfaitement et troisièmement et ce fut
d'ailleurs les points les plus discutés
à ce moment-là de choisir moi-même les
rapporteurs de cette commission
de façon à ne pas me laisser imposer et
quoi que ce soit par du pouvoir public
et je dois le dire que ces conditions
ont été respectées nous avons pu
travailler librement et cette commission
a ensuite rendu un rapport unanime
consensuellement nous n'avons jamais
voté au sens propre mais nous avons tous
j'ai tout fait en tout cas moi en tant
que président de cette commission pour
que nous n'acceptions aucune proposition
qui ne soit pas acceptée par tous
inutile de dire comme vous l'avez
vous-même signé que la question des
taxis était une question très
minoritaire presque minuscule au regard
de tout ce que nous avions traité
puisque sur 316 propositions s'en est
que l'une d'entre elles mais nous avions
conscience que cette proposition allait
susciter beaucoup de bruit et d'ailleurs
ça a pas manqué puisqu'il y a une des
manifestations de taxi le soir même de
la remise du rapport au point que les
débats que nous avons eu c'est au fond
on pourrait très bien de pas en parler
parce que
ça va un peu noyer tout ce que nous
avons à traiter par ailleurs je rappelle
ainsi le manque une des propositions que
j'avais en fait c'était la retraite par
point
qui se trouve dans ce rapport parmi
beaucoup d'autres réformes radicales que
nous avions
proposé dans ce contexte sur la question
proprement dit des taxis comme vous
l'avez éteint justement signalé à
l'époque pas question de quoi que ce
soit
j'ai d'ailleurs moi-même sur ce sujet
comme sur beaucoup d'autres refusés
d'entendre le point de vue qui que ce
soit en particulier je n'ai pas
auditionné
les compagnies de taxi ni accepter de
les recevoir d'ailleurs je dois dire que
c'est à leur honneur ils me l'ont pas
demandé même si André Rousselet était un
ami personnel mais personne m'a demandé
quoi que ce soit et ça c'est une façon
très passée très élégamment
notre préoccupation a été d'abord de
faire en sorte de ce sujet ne
cannibalisent pas la totalité du rapport
ce sur One auront un peu échoué puisque
quand souvent on parle de commission par
les taxis
et de se trouver une solution simple il
y avait trop peu de taxis à Paris il en
fallait plus il fallait donc plus de
plaques mais il fallait pas que plus de
plaques nuisent à ceux qui en avait une
donc la solution était assez simple
c'était de créer les conditions pour qui
est plus de plaques mais indemniser ceux
qui pouvaient y perdre c'est ça que nous
avons proposé avec aussi d'ailleurs une
réglementation beaucoup plus sévère pour
les voitures de place ce qu'on appelait
ainsi cela à cette époque
j'ai toujours pensé même si je l'ai pas
approfondie cette question beaucoup
ensuite que si les syndicats de taxi à
l'époque avaient
accepté cette proposition
leur situation était meilleure que ce
qu'elle a été quand ils se sont trop
confrontés au tsunami des des
plateformes
ultérieures mais ça c'est leur choix
nous ne l'avions proposé je crois de
créer quelques milliers de place en plus
je crois qu'il manque les 6000 plaques à
Paris à cette époque en tout cas il y
avait 6000 personnes qui demandaient une
plaque parmi ceux qui étaient salariés
ou pas et nous avions proposé d'en créer
autant que nécessaire mais des plaques
incessibles c'est-à-dire des plaques qui
ne créent pas une valeur marchande
voilà j'ai rien de plus à dire à vous
dire que cela
je pense que dans les circonstances à la
fois politique culturelles et
technologiques de l'époque c'était la
seule solution qu'on pouvait proposer
mais encore une fois c'était vraiment un
aspect tout à fait particulier et
minuscule de ce rapport d'ensemble
oui merci de le préciser effectivement
je voudrais pas induire en erreur c'est
un rapport avec des centaines de
propositions sur énormément de secteurs
qui étaient potentiellement source de
création d'emplois ou de richesse en les
ouvrant les modernisant ou les libérants
sur est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
un peu de la réaction politique et la
réaction des taxis je crois que le
présent Sarkozy donc avait reçu votre
rapport et il avait lancé une tentative
alors de suivre vos recommandations
d'abord ce rapport au moment où il a été
élaboré a été l'objet de d'énormément de
publicités séance inaugurale de la
Commission a été retransmise en direct à
la télévision il y a tous les débats ont
été suivis de façon très très
approfondie et la séance de remise du
rapport à l'Élysée a été également
télévisée en direct à la télévision et
le président Sarkozy avait dans son
discours dit que il approuvait et
appliquerait toutes les propositions
sauf 3
à mon souvenir les trois étaient
la
une certaine propulsion sur la
décentralisation
rapprochement entre commune et
Communauté de Communes une proposition
sur
une deuxième que j'oublie mais je me
souviens que la troisième était
la vente des produits libres non non sur
ordonnance en grande surface dans l'une
des pharmacies il y a une troisième qui
n'était pas les taxis mais je vais
peut-être elle va peut-être me regarde
mais il avait dit tout le reste je
l'appliquerai et donc y compris y
compris cette proposition sur les taxis
et à ce moment-là nous n'avons pas eu
comme rôle de faire un service
après-vente sauf si bien que nous avons
fait je crois 6 ou un an plus tard un
autre rapport de suivi dans lequel à mon
souvenir il n'était plus question des
taxis puisque assez vite le gouvernement
avait dit qu'il ne l'appliquerait pas
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
donc la la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement décide de ne pas suivre la
conception je pense que il y a eu une
sorte de avoir en tout cas lobbying
énorme visible des syndicats des
peut-être aussi des propriétaires ça je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'était
visible il y avait des blocages partout
je dois dire que ma vie personnelle
n'était pas facilité non plus et même si
moi même je m'étais pas occupé de ça
d'ailleurs pour l'historique de cette
commission j'avais chargé un second de
travail composé de trois membres de la
commission de s'occuper de cette de
cette question
mais je pense que il a
sans doute a juste titre considérer que
c'était créer un
abcès de fixation qui permettait pas de
voir tout le reste et moi-même je comme
dans la commission nous étions assez
nombreux à penser que peut-être il
aurait mieux valu pas traiter cette
question du tout ce qui était une
certaine forme de l'acheter mais c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a fait quand même mais
ça nous aurait permis de focaliser sur
le reste donc voilà j'ai pas été
d'ailleurs informé autrement que par la
presse du fait que cette décision
n'était pas pris en compte quand nous
avons rencontré des représentants par
exemple syndicaux de des taxis
aujourd'hui
on a posé la question
de la de l'insuffisance de l'offre par
rapport à la demande alors vous parlez
des 6000 plaques là on parle même des
emplois potentiellement créés mais par
rapport à la demande quand on compare à
d'autres grandes capitales il y a
toujours les fameux exemple de Londres
New York ou même ou même Madrid ou
Berlin est-ce que
l'analyse que vous portiez à l'époque
dans ce rapport était qu'en effet la
France à cause de cette régulation avait
une offre
c'était à l'époque une évidence personne
trouve un taxi à Paris quoi c'était
c'était une évidence il y avait un
manque claire de de plaque tout le monde
les chiffres que vous venez de rappeler
le disait mais c'était vécu de façon
très très précise oui la plaque elle est
très chère
je pense d'ailleurs qu'elle vaut
aujourd'hui pratiquement le même prix
qu'elle va aller à l'époque un peu moins
peut-être pas beaucoup pas beaucoup
moins peut-être peut-être 30 ou 40% de
moins donc pas beaucoup moins me
semble-t-il
à l'époque et on est
plutôt sur 48
et quel regard d'économistes vous portez
à ce moment-là sur l'arrivée du secteur
des VTC est-ce que en France comme
ailleurs
est-ce qu'on est là dans un nouvel
entrant qui vient disrupter pour faire
un anglicisme un marché qui était selon
vous en fait trop protégé trop régulier
qui n'a pas su se remettre en question
c'était l'opportunité oui c'est
la régulation qui n'a pas su s'adapter
si la régulation s'était adaptée il y
avait pas eu de place pour ses mains
pour ces nouveaux entrants
quand vous avez une digue qui résiste
trop et si vous la modifiez pas la
dix-seine et c'est pire et c'est ce qui
s'est passé la digue ACD et le pire est
arrivé
j'ajoute qu'à l'époque il y avait non
seulement pas les plateformes mais il y
avait pas non plus le GPS donc la
formation nécessaire des chauffeurs de
taxi était un peu non plus exigeante
qu'elle pourrait l'être aujourd'hui
donc la situation était complètement
différente je pense qu'une une
très belle exemple ou métaphore de ce
que quand la religion ne s'adapte pas
elle saute pour le pire voilà et c'est
ce qui s'est passé pour le pire alors je
vais filer là dessus est-ce que quel
regard vous portez sur le marché
aujourd'hui en fait entre les taxis et
les VTC est-ce que selon vous en fait on
aurait été dans une meilleure situation
si précisément les taxis au lieu de
faire un lobby ou des blocages à
l'époque pour empêcher les tentatives de
réformes que vous et d'autres
préconisiez est-ce qu'on serait
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui
serait plus favorable ou finalement on a
une nouvelle forme de concurrence qui
est arrivée je construis dans une
situation plus favorable pour tout le
monde parce qu'il y aurait une offre
plus grande et les chauffeurs de taxi
aurait été davantage protégés dans leur
statut aujourd'hui le fait qu'on
n'arrive pas encore à l'échelle
européenne contrairement à ce que pour
ma part je souhaiterais tout en ayant
pas de mon mois à dire évidemment que
les les
collaborateurs de ces plateformes soient
considérées comme des salariés et en
ayant tous les droits des salariés à
créer une condition de une situation de
d'exploitation extrême
qui n'est pas conforme à l'esprit
français du droit
de vous dites vous vous êtes favorable à
l'avancée de la directive européenne par
exemple de présomption de salariat
exactement
et permettez-moi cette question un peu
malicieuse donc si certains des
rapporteurs qui auraient pu travailler à
vos côtés dans cette commission avait
été amenée à travailler sur sur ce sujet
par la suite en tant que décideur pour
vous il y a une continuité sur le
constat en fait qui était fait de
l'insuffisance de l'offre et de la
nécessité
non je ne sais pas si les rapporteurs ou
qui que ce soit ensuite continué d'une
façon d'une autre à travailler sur ce
sujet je n'ai jamais été saisi de cette
question par personne
est-ce que vous avez des questions
oui alors
pour revenir à l'époque et à votre
rapport vous choisissez
Emmanuel Macron qui est à ce moment-là
et je n'ai Narc pour en être le
rédacteur
quel lien ensuite
pourrez-vous avoir avec lui je voudrais
surtout savoir à l'époque par rapport au
conflit
que poser les taxis vous dites
j'assume et je revendique finalement de
n'avoir auditionné aucun taxi ni les
syndicats patronaux représentants des
intérêts de la G7 pour faire vivre ni
les syndicats de salariés ou de
locataires
gérantes taxi
pour autant à la fin il va tout ça va
aboutir un accord alors peut-être qu'il
faudrait que je me fasse repréciser
la situation mais il me semble que les
fédérations je dirais pas trop mal des
plus proches d'intérêt de la G7 vont
finalement signer un accord pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de nouvelles licences de
taxi mise sur le marché en échange de la
création et le lancement de beaucoup
plus de de VTC et donc de la
libéralisation du secteur et que c'est
ce c'est ce je pars reprendre le terme
guide mais c'est ce
cette négociation finalement qui va qui
va avoir lieu et
vous vous avez dit par la suite quand la
législation ne s'adapte pas elle explose
pour le pire
donc finalement peut-être que l'enjeu
n'était pas tant d'introduire plus de
libéralisme
mais de faire évoluer la régulation
parce que là aujourd'hui on a quel
regard vous portez vous qui avez donc
porté ce rapport pour la libération de
la croissance et je sais que pour moi
les mots ont un sens et j'ai toujours
été très choqué de l'utilisation de ce
terme-là je dirais vu le projet très
néolibéral qu'il portait
qu'elle regarde vous portez sur le fait
que par la suite par la loi Novelli et
par la suite les plateformes type Hubert
et bien d'autres on puisse développer
dans la suite logique idéologique de
votre rapport mais en bas foi plein de
lois de la République et plein de
réglementations qu'elle regarde vous
portez là-dessus alors que vous venez en
même temps de dire que finalement il
faudrait revenir à la direction présente
son de salariat donc à une défense du
Code du travail très renforcée
madame pour vous de dire
que il n'y avait rien de néolibéral ni
dans l'idéologie de ce rapport ni dans
mon idéologie personnelle ni dans les
logis de la commission il faut le dire
et pas se contenter de quelques
approximations à la volée ce rapport est
en rapport qui a été signé par des noms
que je pourrais citer très proche de la
CGT très proche de la CFDT très proche
de la gauche dans ce cas-là de meilleur
et qui n'est rien en rien ni
idéologiquement ni dans les mesures
qu'il propose néolibéral
selon moi et selon les membres de cette
commission dont j'ai l'honneur de vous
dire que la moitié était et se considère
aujourd'hui encore comme de gauche ils
sont très fiers de ce rapport et sont
très fiers d'être encore de gauche
quant au choix du rapporteur je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure le président Sarkozy ou
c'est collaborateurs auraient souhaité
que je prenne les collaborateurs du
Président comme rapporteur ce qui est
évidemment une façon de se mettre entre
les mains de ne pouvoir en place pour
écrire les choses et j'ai donc
demandé à avoir la liberté de choisir
les rapporteur et je n'avais pas de nom
en tête
et donc j'ai simplement demandé au
Conseil d'État et à l'Inspection des
finances de me fournir le nom de trois
jeunes brillants et j'ai choisi comme
rapporteur général Jocelyne de Clausade
membre du Conseil d'État et comme
rapporteur général adjoint un jeune
inspecteur des finances qui était
extrêmement compétent
l'actuel président de la République
nous avons tous travaillé ensemble il y
avait d'ailleurs énormément d'autres
personnes et la plume n'a pas été tenue
seulement par les rapporteurs mais elle
a été tenue aussi par les membres de la
commission nous avons tous travaillé
beaucoup des dimanches des samedis et
des dimanches entiers à écrire ce texte
qui est donc un texte tout à fait
collectif ensuite je n'ai pas la moindre
idée de ce qui s'est passé sur les taxis
je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a été
entendu je ne sais pas si il y a eu des
négociations sur des lois aucune idée
j'ai rien à dire pour ce qui est de du
fond ce que nous avions en tête c'était
vraiment tout simplement de faire qui
est plus de taxi à Paris et en province
tout simplement dans le respect du droit
du travail
donc notre seul préoccupation sur ce
sujet encore une fois
minuscule sur regarde l'ampleur du
rapport notre seul préoccupation était
de faire en sorte que il y ait davantage
de taxi disponible
qu'ensuite ça s'est négocié de cette
façon et à bien après la maladie il
faudra regarder le calendrier que la
Commission est rendu son rapport avec
une chose qui m'a totalement été
étranger
et quel regard vous vous portez
aujourd'hui sur toutes les nuisances en
fait des plateformes à la fois pour
l'économie des finances publiques
puisqu'elle ne paye pas de cotisation
sociale puisqu'elle prétendent avoir à
faire à des
indépendants alors que beaucoup de
décisions de justice montrent qu'il
s'agit en fait de fausses indépendants
il y a aussi un non-paiement d'impôt sur
les sociétés puisque bien souvent ces
plateformes se déclarent dans des pays
alors soit propice au paradis fiscaux
soit une fiscalité autre
non paiement de la TVA également
distorsion de concurrence par rapport au
taxi qu'elle regarde vous portez sur sur
tout cela
d'abord je vous dis si je peux me
permettre madame la parlementaire c'est
à vous de faire votre travail
c'est à vous de faire la loi et de faire
en sorte que la loi assure la protection
du travailleur
s'il faut la faire à Paris il faut la
faire à Bruxelles mais il faut la faire
il y a des parles il y a un Parlement
européen c'est à vous à faire en sorte
que les conditions de travail soient les
plus protectrices possibles des salariés
vous ce que vous dites est exact et je
partage ce diagnostic il est d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus vaste là encore que la
question des taxis il renvoie à
quelque chose dont je parle beaucoup
dans beaucoup de mes travaux par
ailleurs mais à la domination du marché
sur la démocratie
le marché mondial la démocratie est
nationale le marché mondial l'emporte et
impose sa loi sur la démocratie et ça
c'est un des grands enjeux que cours nos
sociétés dont on voit quelques
manifestations ici mais de
manifestations beaucoup plus importantes
dans beaucoup d'autres domaines où
aussi longtemps qu'il n'y a pas une
réglementation nationale forte ou une
réglementation internationale capable de
rivaliser avec la puissance des
multinationales nous allons vers une un
marché mondial sans État de droit qui
imposera sa règle au en droit du travail
comme dans d'autres domaines à des
sociétés qui ensuite pour le pire
choisiront de se faire former de se
fermer en totalitarisme ou en populisme
pour éviter provisoirement
la règle du marché
parce que ça ne marchera pas non plus
la seule chose qui marchera c'est une
règle internationale forte
ou les démocraties imposeront ensemble
une règle forte internationale qui
protégera les travailleurs ces règles
existent elles ont été édictées par dans
le domaine qui nous importe par
l'Organisation internationale du travail
il faudrait simplement que
l'organisation internationale soit
écouter par exemple si on disait qu'un
pays qui ne respecte pas les
réglementations internationales du
travail n'est pas autorisé à exporter
selon les règles de l'OMC on aurait
changé pratiquement toutes les sujets
qui nous concernent
très loin c'est de la science-fiction
politique dont je parle là
un protectionnisme social écologique
n'est pas forcément une fiction
politique ça peut être tout simplement
un projet politique
ma question
à condition qu'il ne s'inscrivent pas
dans du populisme
vous définirez cette donnée parce que il
peut y avoir deux interprétations voilà
se préoccuper respecter la souveraineté
du peuple et celle et l'expression de
ses représentants peut être considérée
par certains de populisme quand ils
abusent de dispositions certes
constitutionnelles mais
anti-démocratique
vous dites il faut faire la loi Paris
comme à Bruxelles je suis pour ma part
très fière de la participation de
députés européens comme les lâchébie
France insoumise dans la bataille pour
la directive européenne présentation du
salariat j'ai assumé d'interpeller
monsieur Dussac qui se dit lui toujours
de gauche et qui afin qu'ils mettent en
débat la position de la France à
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
directive présomption de salariats alors
que pour l'instant tous ceux qui nous
revient c'est plutôt que la France
souhaite torpiller cette directive
européenne et cette enquête cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire
travaille également sur l'ensemble des
manquements de l'État dans le dans le
contrôle donc vous avez exprimé vous
votre
soutien pour cette directive présomption
de salariat et du coup quel regard vous
portez sur les conséquences d'une
application de la présomption de
salariat
face à une situation lubérisation s'est
étendue à plein de secteurs
à chaque fois d'ailleurs on mépris des
des
régulations de ces secteurs je pense par
exemple à la filiale Stuart de La Poste
à staffie qui propose des
aides-soignants à l'hôpital ou à brigade
dans les hôtels café-restaurants ou à
getir et flingue dans le Quick commerce
je ne parle pas de ces sujets que je ne
connais pas de façon spécifique mais je
crois que le droit du travail tel qu'il
est défini dans un pays doit s'appliquer
d'une façon générale et le droit du
travail doit être il doit y avoir une
sorte de clause du travailleur le plus
le plus protégé qui s'applique à tous
J'ai rien de plus à dire
à nos collègues pour voir s'il y a des
questions complémentaires
je vous en prie
si j'ai essayé d'être à pile parce que
je sais que vous devez être libéré à
midi alors je voulais premier point que
vous me confirmiez que vous avez refusé
de recevoir les taxis deuxième point
et vous n'avez pas demandé donc en fait
vous ne l'avez pas souhaité voilà
deuxième question pourquoi et troisième
question chirurgiendrai c'est à dire que
vous avez interpellé tout à l'heure ma
collègue députée en disant vous c'était
au parlementaire comme s'il n'y avait
une responsabilité tout ça que sur les
députés et on y reviendra tout à l'heure
je voudrais d'abord que vous répondiez à
ma deuxième question pourquoi avoir
refusé les taxis et étiez-vous conscient
que pensez-vous plutôt de
[Musique]
des inconvénients que ça allait procurer
à la profession est-ce que vous étiez
sensible à ça que pensez-vous de ça
comment vous vous voyez les choses à ce
moment là
encore une fois personne m'a demandé
d'être sûr en tout cas par mois
peut-être par d'autres membres de la
commission j'en sais rien et d'autre
part j'avais veillé très soigneusement à
ne pas recevoir les lobbies j'ai je
pourrais vous raconter pendant des
heures les pressions des uns et des
autres dans d'autres professions qui ont
souhaité être su faire valoir leur point
de vue et qu'on a essayé autant qu'on a
pu de tenir à distance de nos travaux
mais là dans ce secteur je dois dire
qu'amorce à mon souvenir je peux être
contredit par d'autres souvenirs à mon
souvenir personne ne nous a rien demandé
et
c'était encore une fois un sujet qui
nous a pas occupé beaucoup de temps dans
la dans la totalité de nos travaux donc
non pas beaucoup de temps je vous dis
une sur 360 316 propositions donc très
peu de temps donc nous
et encore une fois je continue à penser
que si les conclusions ne se rapportent
avaient été appliquée la situation était
bien meilleure pour les pour les taxis
oui peut-être ne pensez-vous pas quand
les recevant et à leur expliquer ça ça
aurait faciliter les choses
encore une fois
je ne sais pas si d'autres membres de la
commission ont pu ce que j'ai souvenir
d'assez précis que j'ai délégué ce
travail un petit groupe peut-être ce
petit groupe à trouver utile de les voir
ou de d'en parler avec eux mais
le rapport était lui-même assez
explicite sur le fait que nous essayons
d'être convaincants sur le fait que
c'était utile pour eux
s'il avait fallu faire sur tous ceux qui
étaient concernés par le rapport de
d'avant-vente ou il aurait fallu voir
tout le monde pour dire à tout le monde
vous avez intérêt à prouver ce rapport
si tu étais une tâche insurmontable
juste la troisième question rapide parce
que tout à l'heure vous avez dit à ma
collègue vous êtes le menteur donc en
gros c'est sur vous que pèse la
responsabilité mais ne pensez-vous pas
quand on est chargé d'une commission les
membres d'un gouvernement ont aussi leur
rôle à jouer sur la législation et sur
le respect d'une législation protectrice
[Musique]
pour un peu la Constitution française
vous avez raison de dire que le
Parlement n'est pas seul responsable de
faire la loi donc je m'adresse au
Parlement parce que je suis en face de
parlementaire ça ne veut pas dire que la
responsabilité est unique et qu'elle
n'est pas partagée
Monsieur Attali les conséquences en fait
de votre rapport c'est pas simplement
les conséquences sur la question des
taxis et je j'entends votre votre
précision qui était de dire vous votre
la commission interdit elle proposait
elle préconisait l'augmentation du
nombre de plaques et l'indemnisation de
ceux qui pouvait y perdre mais elle ne
préconisait pas forcément la création
du statut du VTC qui allait permettre
par la suite aux plateformes de
prospérer et donc de risquer même à un
moment donné
d'amener la perte totale de la
profession de taxi il y en a certains
qui se sont suicidés face à
l'effondrement de leur de la valeur de
leur licence pour autant c'est bien
suite à la commission que vous avez
présidé
que la création du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur alors pour protéger
en fait
celles et ceux qui souhaitaient
commencer dans le micro entrepreneuriat
a été créé or aujourd'hui les
plateformes et l'ubérisations dans son
ensemble s'appuie énormément sur la
surexploitation de ce statut qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
malheureusement il y a peu de temps avec
un sujet passionnant
je pense en effet que le statut
d'entrepreneur que d'ailleurs nous
revendiquions comme une des propositions
de ce rapport à mon souvenir est une
bonne idée j'ai d'ailleurs moi-même en
tant que président d'une association qui
travaille dans les quartiers pour aider
les jeunes à créer leur emploi dans les
qpv en particulier
fait beaucoup pour essayer de faire en
sorte que ce statut soit pris et
permettre aux entreprises de créer leur
entreprise pour commencer sans doute
faudrait-il mais j'improvise ici en
parlant
distinguer les auto-entrepreneurs
indépendants des auto-entrepreneurs qui
s'inscrivent dans un réseau
à partir du moment où il s'inscrit dans
un réseau il rejoignent assez vite un
statut de quasi salarié dans ce cas-là
touchant mais quelqu'un qui est
auto-entrepreneur pour envoyer une
boutique c'est pas la même chose que
quelqu'un qui auto-entrepreneur pour
prendre du franchise c'est pas du tout
pareil donc c'est là où je crois que se
trouve la frontière
et une réponse effectivement très claire
et très intéressante qui va je pense pas
mal nous aider dans l'avancée nos
travaux sur sur le sujet je présente mes
excuses à mon collègue députés isards
comme nous avons pris Monsieur Attali en
retard je veux pas en plus lui infliger
la double peine je veux bien prendre une
dernière question
merci beaucoup
pardon merci beaucoup je veux vraiment
pas être cette double peine mais
simplement moi j'avais une question très
très rapide c'est vrai que l'arrivée de
des VTC de manière générale en France
ont un petit peu comblé un point de
votre apport qui est le manque d'offres
de manière générale mais est-ce que vous
croyez que donc c'est arrivé qui amène
certains points positifs qui comble
cette offre là mais certains autres
points négatifs une limite un
capacité profonde de continuer à
développer le taxi en parallèle du
développement de ces plateformes là
c'est ce qui se passe en France je crois
qu'il y a aujourd'hui des taxis et des
VTC donc
ça prouve que ça fonctionne
il faut simplement éviter que les taxis
soit en situation de rente et de
monopole et que les VTC soit en
situation d'exploitation
catastrophique de l'emploi donc c'est
c'est il faut éviter les deux c'est à
dire l'extrait de l'excès de la
concentration et à l'inverse d'excès de
l'exploitation
bien monsieur attaque je vous remercie
infiniment je pense que c'était vraiment
un éclairage important de prendre aussi
un petit peu de recul par rapport à la
période sur laquelle nous concentrons
pour voir à quel point ces sujets
étaient prégnants avant et le sont
toujours aujourd'hui effectivement
certaines réflexion que vous venez de
livrer sur la question de
l'entrepreneuriat je pense en
particulièrement
utile dans nos travaux je vous souhaite
encore une bonne journée je vous
remercie merci de m'avoir entendu